with a disappointing iPad Pro refresh
and the 10th generation iPad that looks
nice but costs a lot more than we
expected and has a few really weird
limitations Apple also released the new
Apple TV 4K and it might actually be the
product that is the most reasonable out
of this whole launch now I've been a
user of the Apple TV for close to a
decade now just because of how well it
integrates into Apple's ecosystem the
menu system being able to use Siri to
find what you're wanting to look for and
much more and with this one I want to
share with you guys every single
difference what has changed and also
some limitations and some weird specs
from Apple now right out of the get-go
apple is advertising their Apple TV
service their shows which are great and
with that they don't really focus on the
specs at all they're just focusing on
the experience some extra features and
apps that you can use with it Apple's
arcade the photos app which I love using
because it's connected to my iCloud and
Apple account but I want to get into the
actual specs and why I ordered one right
away and of course that's coming in
November now the first biggest
difference is the price it is now 129
dollars compared to 179 and that is
thanks to Apple killing off the Apple TV
HD which was actually 149 bucks it was
more expensive and that thing used the
processor from the iPhone 6 which came
out in 2014 so it's crazy that they were
still selling it at that price point so
that's a drop of 50 dollars but if you
look closer the base storage is now
doubled and if you wanted to get 64 gig
last year that actually cost you 200
which means it's a 70 difference and
this year you can actually get up to 128
for 20 bucks more so now the pricing is
way better than before but with that if
you get that 128 gig model so you also
get gigabit Ethernet which you got
before and thread networking support
thread is used to seamlessly connect
hundreds of products like door locks
thermostats appliances and much more
they can actually talk to each other
expand your range so that is great but
that actually was included with last
year's Apple TV 4K and that means that
if you go ahead and buy that base model
that is no longer included and you lose
ethernet now Apple actually made this
Apple TV 4K smaller and lighter now it's
funny that people are talking about well
you know that's a huge Improvement
obviously sarcastically because weight
doesn't matter in fact it's actually
worse because you do have cables
sticking out the back that can tug on
that now they're able to do that because
they removed the fan cooling that was in
there before and now it's fanless a lot
of people said they don't even know that
there was a fan in there because it was
so quiet and that is because they went
with the a15 which is five nanometer
it's more efficient than the a12 that we
had previously I'll talk about
performance here in just a bit and one
little weird weirdness about it but with
I would say they should definitely spend
extra 20 bucks not only to get the
storage but the extra features now with
that we have a change to the remote now
this remote they released last year
replacing that flat one and it was a
nice upgrade in my opinion but it had a
lightning connector and now we have USB
type-c which I think they should have
just done right away I don't keep
lightning cables around we use wireless
charging so when it's time to charge
it's a bit of a pain but USB type-c we
do have now I personally use Wi-Fi and
thankfully it has been improved even
though it's still Wi-Fi six it has a 2x2
mimo multiple in multiple out instead of
a one by one and sometimes in my
basement I do have issues with uh the
connection speed so that is going to be
nice now what I'm more interested is the
addition of HDR 10 plus now not
everything uses that a lot of things use
Dolby Vision but in certain apps like
YouTube for example or Amazon time you
can use HDR 10 plus and that adds extra
metadata to your HDR which makes sure
that the HR content looks its best for
your display and it could definitely
make a noticeable difference and that
was a downside previously not having
that now I would think that they could
add that in to the previous Apple TV 4K
but I guess it is just with this one now
as far as the video output this thing
has HDMI 2.1 which means it can support
4K 60 with HDR it could also support 4K
120 and AK for that connection but apple
is not allowing you to do that it is
just locked into 4K 60. now that is a
bummer because my Xbox for example it
could support 4K 120. now I don't know
if apple is going to add that in the
future for example 8K YouTube videos can
stream that but this device well
wouldn't support that with that av1 as
well and I don't think apple is probably
going to add that until they have their
own content that could support it and
then they might even lock it down to
buying a new Apple TV to do so even
though that HDMI connector can do so and
now let's talk about the a15 that is in
this device compared to the a12 in last
year's generation that is a big jump and
apple said that we're gonna get a 50
Improvement in performance for the CPU
and the graphics is a little different
now if you take a look at the scores
from those chips we had a big jump in
single core performance larger than the
50 they quoted and as far as multi-core
performance we have the same thing it is
basically double the performance with
Apple only quoting 50 now I mentioned
that we no longer have the fan in this
updated model it's just using passive
Cooling and that might be why the their
quoted performance that still sounds
great doesn't match up to the actual
test we have from these chips in other
Apple devices now when we move over to
metal if you're doing gaming decoding
all that stuff they quoted a 30
Improvement but looking at the scores
for those chips we literally have more
than double the performance comparing
the a12 to the a15 in metal and based
off of their 30 percent that they gave
which sounds good that would only bring
us up to about 7
000 estimated metal score not over 11
000 which is what the a15 is capable of
and that's the a15 in the iPhone 13
that's the four core GPU model not the
five core that came in the iPhone 13
Pros or the new iPhone 14s which are
even more powerful so why do we have
such a discrepancy in the actual
performance compared to what it should
be well I think for one we don't really
need that level of performance as I
mentioned we don't have 4K 120 out of
that HDMI it's limited 4k60 the games
aren't that difficult cold but I think
it might just be because of that passive
cooling they want sustained performance
and maybe capping it down just lowers
the power usage they think it's going to
do well enough and of course I think the
biggest change why I think of an a15
which sounds impressive but the
performance is not a 15 performance it's
just because they're Mass manufacturing
those chips the a15 costs I think less
than half of what the a16 costs and
they're no longer making devices with
the older chip so why not you know throw
that in there they're going to cap it
down maybe even there's worse performing
chips that just don't bin as well
they're going to toss that in there and
of course your device here is 129 or 149
not a very expensive you know iPad or
iPhone so with all that said who should
upgrade to this new Apple TV 4K well if
you have the HD version which they were
still selling up until now of course
that is a no-brainer and even if you
have the Apple TV 4K which I think was
2017 when that one came out it is a
no-brainer because we have so much more
formats the hardware decoding way way
better performance as well uh you cannot
do 4K 60 with HDR uh that's going to be
a really nice jump you also have the new
remote instead of the previous flat you
know candy bar style remote so I like
that as far as an improvement that is
worth it but if you have one from last
year which has that same remote not that
much of a difference well I think for
most people it is not going to be worth
it now of course I mentioned I ordered
it it's going to be coming in November
and I think for me having the HDR 10
plus knowing that the HDR content from
YouTube from Amazon Prime from the
Google Play Store that it's going to
look its best that is great also the
better reception because they don't have
ethernet over there having that better
connection is going to be nice and being
able to charge that remote what the
cables actually do have around that's
going to be good as well and I've had a
couple stutters occasionally I don't
know what was going on so maybe
performance will be improved but you
guys let me know what you think and with
that if you guys want to check out one
of those great iPad videos right there
they're super interesting if you haven't
seen me yet check them out click that
Circle above to subscribe This One Max
and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]